the federal reserve might want to fix
your wallet
by turning it from this into this though
your wallet is still designed for dollar
bills
americans have been using cash to buy
things less and less over the years
that's part of why the fed is
considering digitizing the us dollar
giving people money they can access on
their phone in bypassing electronic
payments that can be slow
and costly for businesses some see this
as a necessary upgrade to the u.s
financial system
but others worry it could potentially
upend commercial banking
there are some very very difficult
questions to answer but i think we
and we are engaged in a serious
program to understand both the
technology and the policy issues
essential bank digital currency or cbdc
is exactly what it sounds like
a purely digital form of a country's
money issued by its central bank that
people can use
just like cash it's true that cards and
apps already allow for electronic
payment
but behind the scenes these financial
transactions involve several steps
settling payments over a patchwork of
systems
the plumbing of the system is still
based on a cash
system josh lipsky is the director of
the atlantic council's geoeconomic
center
and says the u.s financial system is
still pretty old school when it comes to
moving money around
you know it's based on banks talking to
banks saying hey i need you to transfer
this to me
we've updated some of that over the
years but he actually if you were to
look back a lot of it dates back to the
1950s and before
and that's not a great way to run a
modern global economy
after a debit card is swiped the
transaction can flow through several
entities including point-of-sale systems
payment networks like visa and
mastercard your bank and the merchants
bank this system can take up to three
days to move money between accounts and
often comes with transaction fees that
can weigh heavily on small businesses
who experts say may have to pass the
cost onto customers or put restrictions
on card usage
these extra costs can limit their
revenues and customer base
cbdc's could bypass this system allowing
digital money to flow directly between
two people
in the same way you hand over cash at
the register one method the fed
is considering is issuing digital
wallets to americans directly
or through commercial banks or other
financial service providers
the digital dollars themselves would be
no more than computer code
possibly stored on a central ledger at
the fed or on a distributed ledger like
many cryptocurrencies
when you use your wallet to pay for
something the fed would take the digital
cash out of your wallet and deposit it
into the merchants
simplifying the process and doing it
without fees
these could be done through an app on a
phone or for those without smartphones
an sms text message or
debit card besides frictionless payments
a digital dollar could help the 8.4
million unbanked households who don't
have a debit or credit card
and can get left behind in a cashless
world for example instead of mailing
checks the government can deposit your
tax refund or stimulus payments directly
into your fed wallet
making the money available immediately
proponents also say cbdc's offer a much
more effective tool for central banks to
enact monetary policy
right now the fed influences interest
rates across the entire economy
by setting borrowing rates between banks
known as the federal funds rate
but this is often a fraught process that
doesn't always produce the desired
results
the fed sets this benchmark rate and
other private banks are supposed to
queue off it and then your mortgage is
supposed to queue off it
does that really work how much time does
it take and the answer that economists
will tell you is it works but they're
probably more efficient ways to transfer
monetary policy
economists believe that if the federal
reserve were to assign interest rates to
the money stored in digital wallets
it would be much more effective at
influencing economic decision-making at
the household level
according to a january survey 60 of
central banks around the world
are currently experimenting with cbdc's
the bahamas was the first country to
release a digital currency
called the sand dollar in october 2020
and china has been developing and
testing a digital version of the yuan
but there are questions about how a
digital currency would work
in the us legitimate digital public
money
could help drive out bogus digital
private money
it could help improve financial
inclusion efficiency
and the safety of our financial system
if
that digital public money is well
designed
and efficiently executed which are two
very big ifs the recent rise of
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin and
private currencies like facebook's dm
have spurred central banks to explore
cbdc's in an effort to keep pace
experts say these alternative currencies
expose the risk of money and payments
circulating outside the watchful eyes of
central banks
this is a blind spot for them because
when they're setting monetary policy
they like to know how much money is in
circulation
broadly how that money is being used and
so that helps them understand the
macroeconomics and the fundamentals of
the economy at any given time
but by keeping up with new competitors
cbdc's could threaten to leave
traditional banking behind
so if the fed were to become a bank in a
traditional sense
and actually issue people money and hold
people's money directly
then you might hold less money in your
bank of america app and that would
cut into their business model so they
have to think about how digital
currencies
affect their business because of these
issues the federal reserve is still
studying the scope and structure of how
a digital dollar would work and how it
could be integrated into the current
banking system
the fed doesn't want to start dealing
with 300 million customers
overnight you know they're not equipped
to do that so you don't want to call up
the fed at midnight and say i forgot my
password this is not something the fed
is
wants to be doing or can do so they need
to think about who to work with to
deliver digital dollars
the fed would also have to tackle
privacy concerns over how anonymous
digital dollar payments should be
and whether the money should be
restricted to specific transactions or
programmed to expire after a certain
time period to encourage spending
it plans to release a discussion paper
on the benefits and risks of a digital
dollar this summer
and has said it wouldn't move forward
without support from congress
many experts say the fed will need to
figure out a digital dollar to keep up
with the pace of a rapidly changing
global economy
what that looks like remains to be seen
but it could mean using this
a lot less